imagine if for the first time our heroes
all lost
[Applause]
[Music]
is no place to die
[Applause]
thanos had his way and half of the
population of the universe has gone
everyone's doing their best to keep
their head above water but it's it's
kind of a losing battle we lost and
we're not used to losing people are kind
of still coming to grips with it
natasha is a little bit hardened from
what she's had to go through
they've truly leveled us not just
literally but morally and emotionally
there was no other way
the fans reaction to the end of infinity
war when half their favorite characters
turn to dust really was indicative of
how emotionally connected the world has
gotten to these characters the good
thing is it's always easier to build
people back up after they've been broken
down man that that's what Marvel is
great at doing its that shred of hope
everyone's looking for
I never said no more surprises but I was
really hoping to pull off one last one
I like this one